Pamela what would you advise someone as
the first step in writing a screenplay
ok the the first step before the first
step is have a brilliant idea then now
that's the art part then you start doing
the craft and what what I always do when
I'm working with writers is to identify
the mythic theme what is the story
they're telling and once you identify
that theme then you can look at the plot
points that go along with that theme
usually Oh 12 to 20 if you hit six of
those plot points whether it's the fatal
attraction theme the stealing fire from
heaven theme the search for the promised
land theme they all have plot points and
you need to hit some of them so that way
your audience will go even unconsciously
or subconsciously will go oh it's that
story yeah like that one okay let's
let's see how this person tells that
story and here again it may just be a
subconscious thing but these are the
stories that are in our collective
unconscious and that we've been telling
each other for thousands and thousands
of years so identify your theme look
into the myth and on your own or working
with someone who does that or working
with a book that outlines it then pick
six plot points that you can use in your
story and don't feel like you have to go
in order you can mix things around but
you need to give us that resin you to
strike those notes so that we recognize
the key that you're playing in so
identify your theme pick out six at
least plot points and then our capaz
just use those five of the warrior the
month scientists the magician and the
lover makes it so much easier than
trying to go through the other many many
archetypes so identify your main three
characters what is their path and then
do you want them to stay there
do you want them to grow into the next
level or are they going to be taken down
to a lower level and then try to
struggle their way back up or maybe
they're switching from one path to
another that's a lot of dramatic
conflict there maybe you've got someone
on the warrior path who wants to give
that up and go be a poet get on the
lover path and so what are the conflicts
there that arise from them shifting
their ARCA path another thing to keep in
mind is symbolism and we all use symbols
all the time it's once again just who we
are it's the oldest form of art right
look at your cave walls right symbols
going on for 70,000 years now there are
three levels of symbolism there's the
emotional personal level there is the
situational or environmental level and
then there is the conceptual level I
like to use the example of avatar
because it has wonderful symbolism when
we first meet Jake the protagonist he's
in a wheelchair he's broken and he just
doesn't care you know I was like sure
I'll go off to this moon who why not
yeah and at the end of it we see him
flying on a dragon free so he's gone
from this physically crippled
emotionally crippled person in a human
body in a wheelchair to this gloriously
free heroic character flying in an
avatar form or transformation and just
those those two vehicles in the
environmental situation all conflict the
symbolism there for me is very effective
just with some of the fights that they
have between the helicopters and the
Dragons ok so it's symbolic of the
meeting of high-tech and
a more natural culture and you bring
those two together there's always
conflict but just those those battles
that you have it's okay there it is
symbolic of everything else that's going
on on the ground then for the conceptual
level of the symbolism in avatar you
have the trees and that
interconnectedness it's about we are all
one life we are all one we are all inter
dependent upon each other whether it's
the trees where the families all live or
it's that special you know the spirit
tree but the tree gives us that symbol
of interconnectedness and on the you
know in the air and in the earth so it's
a real grounded thing and it's it's a
wonderful symbol but so well done in
that movie
you